Robert aside from crowdsource studios
and all of the scripts that you've
written you've also written a book right
rejected true tales of nearly overlooked
greatness you mean this one care haha
perfect timing great all right nice
happen to have closed it happen to be
there okay and you dedicate the book to
whom gosh you tell me you tell me I
don't remember well you say here i'm
gonna i have a quote here my hope is
that at least one person out there will
read these true stories of perseverance
despite adversity and become inspired so
you said that its dedicated anyone who's
had a dream in spite of everything who
chase his dream spite of every thought
yeah okay yeah gonna get ya so you wrote
it when where were you in your life well
i had just gotten rejected for something
i was up for a pilot deal with i guess i
shouldn't mention the network and i got
turned down for at the end of the day
and and i had always heard this quote
this this sort of infamous quote the
quote was can't act can't sing bald can
dance a little and that was infamously
said by the head of RKO casting in 1933
i think about an unknown fred astaire
who had just auditioned for him and it's
such a great story and you know i
started thinking about that gatekeepers
and you know tastemakers and they're not
always right I started thinking I wonder
if there were other stories like that
with famous people who later became
famous and well respected and well known
who had been rejected early on and I did
some research and it seems that Sam it
was amazing to me how many in all areas
from artists musicians writers i came
across original rejection letter letters
fleck for Hemingway and so forth and I
mean the Beatles for example they I
didn't know this but in 1962 i think it
was New Year's Day I believe in 62 the
unknown Beatles drove down from
Liverpool and auditioned for decca
records live in the studio
they did 10 songs and the head of Decca
Records was like man you guys aren't
going anywhere The Beatles Elvis was
told you know you ought to go back to
driving a truck you're never going to
make it and there are so many stories
like that so it was just it was sort of
galvanizing to me it was inspiring to
know that these great you know the
gatekeepers are often wrong so yeah
that's working about
you